hi my name is paracosma Cassie I'm
kernel developer apothem research and
today I will be talking about linear and
quadratic convex optimization models
so Rob mentioned that he gave the
overview of you know convex optimization
I'm gonna focus on linear and quadratic
optimization models so just to give you
guys an overview or rather a reminder of
what convex optimization as you know
you're basically minimizing a certain
function subject to a certain constraint
and what makes it convex is that it
satisfies this certain inequality okay I
won't Rob showed a couple of graphics
you know about how a function is convex
you know based on based on this
inequality but let's just let's just
focus on this part and see what forms
the these functions F take to be
classified under either linear or
quadratic models so if I were to is this
big enough for you for the people in the
back to see yes okay yeah somebody says
alright if if the objective function so
f naught is linear and the constraints
are also linear then it's considered a
linear optimization problem if it is if
the objective function is you know the
ratio of two linear functions then that
becomes a linear fractional optimization
if your objective function has this form
which is a quadratic form where Q is a
matrix then it becomes a quadratic
optimization problem and if you and if
your objective function is linear but
your but your objective about your
constraints have this norm in into in
them then that's the second-order cone
optimization okay and it's not hard to
see that you know the second-order cone
is sort of the most general one but like
quadratic optimization is like a subset
of quadratic and second order and you
know the other ones also can be
converted into into other ones so so
linear and quadratic themselves can
passive very large set of models but you
can extend that models by doing these
transformations and Rob showed a number
of these transformations these are some
of the popular transformations so if
you're ever open up a book on
optimization here and and you're
interested in doing some practical
modeling you're bound to come up run
into these these kind of transformations
so if you want to do some kind of four
norm one optimization you know you can
convert that into using some
transformations you can convert that
into a linear optimization model same
thing with an infinity norm if you want
to do some infinity norm minimization
same thing you convert them you know
that it gets transformed into a set of
linear constraints Rob showed an example
of absolute x here is a nice fancy way
that you can represent absolute value of
X using two auxiliary variables if you
want to tell you know convert you know a
set of linear functions and you want to
find the maximum of that then again you
have these transformations so using
these transformations you can extend the
scope of linear and quadratic
optimization models that's that's the
point I'm trying to make here so let's
let's jump into linear optimization
model so the syntax that we have in in
Mathematica is linear optimization it
can it will have an objective which is a
symbolic objective you'll have
constraints oniony love variables but we
also allow you to directly give vectors
and matrices vector objectives and
matrix constraints in order to solve the
problem directly if you are getting
confused as to you know why are we
calling stuff optimization linear
programming is what it was called before
and and we had a function called linear
programming for a very long time and we
still do in in Mathematica optimization
is is just like a it's like a more 90s
name because you know we lost rights to
programming in the in the optimization
community and so so that's so that's why
we have linear optimization now but
under the hood linear optimization is
basically making use
the same functions and the libraries to
solve the problem now I want to go back
just a for just a minute because that's
sort of the whole point is still how you
properly give the inputs into into these
optimization functions that make it
obvious and easy to use and Rob spend a
good amount of time talking about you
know all these vector inequalities and
this modeling paradigm that you could
that that you could use to your benefit
so there are obvious the obvious ways
that you can that you can give an input
so let's take this specific example you
want to minimize X plus y subjected some
constraint the most obvious way to do
that is to give it in a symbolic form
this is you know and and then just run
it or you can convert this into matrix
vectors and matrices so the X plus y is
one one right and then these constraints
can be can be mapped into this matrix
and a vector and you can give that as an
input it's not the most intuitive one
you have to do a little bit of mental
calculation but if this becomes really
helpful for example if you import the
data from some you know from some
external source where and they might
have it in this matrix vector form so we
provide that capability for you but the
most important thing especially from a
modeling point of view is that you can
use these vector variables and and so
again you can use these vector these
coefficients and you just dot them with
a vector variable v and the internal
parsing system recognizes that V is a
vector it's got a certain dimension and
it just goes out and solves the problem
for you right you can use vector greater
equal or vector less equal which allows
you to group a number of constraints all
into one and that's a real that makes
life a lot simpler and you can use this
escape notation and and Rob quickly
alluded to that you know you can use
this SK
so let's try that here escape V greater
equal escape and that brings that little
squiggly rather this curvy inequality
thing into place and when you do that it
the the thing starts becoming smaller
and smaller so again linear optimization
same thing happens or you could use this
parameter equations right and it's a
it's a it's a question of convenience
and what works best sometimes and I'll
show you examples we're in using matrix
vector form seems to be the most
efficient way to represent a problem
just obvious and in some cases using
symbolic methods are just the more
obvious choice so let's look at linear
optimization examples the very first one
we're going to tackle is data fitting
because that's sort of very rigorous
we're gonna focus on robust data fitting
which is minimizing using the l1 norm
and I talked about the l1 norm and the
transformations you can do with that
so here's your here's the raw data it's
noisy data I'm going to fit a curve
through it I'm gonna use this multi
quadric basis functions and then you'll
end up with this interpolating function
so you objective here is to is to try
and find these lambdas okay so that's
your basis I'm going to use ten of them
spread at equal intervals I'm going to
use design matrix to generate an input
so this is going to be a matrix then I'm
going to solve this l1 or problem so
this input is your a here okay and B is
your output so a is the input B is the
output that's the transformation I took
that takes place and you're trying to
minimize the total of s how about that
something changed in it
try it hundred times before and now it
decides to it there we go alright so
that's that's your lambda and that's
your s end of course you can plot it and
that's your result it's as simple as
that right so you can see that the
modeling allows you to the actual
problem-solving happens in rather just
one line and and if you just look at it
long enough you can actually read the
problem statement directly from the code
if if you if need be here's the second
example which is a classification
problem you have two sets of data and
you just want to you know separate these
two sets of data and you want to find
you'll find like a line that separates
these these two sets right so the way
you would do that is you want one the
first set to obey this constraint that
you know that the line on the on one
side should be greater than or equal to
1 on the other should be less than or
equal to minus 1 so that gives a good
separation between these two sets of
points notice that there is no objective
because technically this is all the
constraints so go ahead and find any
line that you want as long as it gives
us a good separation so we solve this
problem
we get a and B which are the
coefficients associated with the
hyperplane and that's your line right so
it separates one from the other I mean
you could you could change this to no be
B is a scalar and it changes a little
bit and that will change that line angle
a little bit so you can you can play
around with it it's it's a lot more
intuitive it allows for more exploration
if need be
ok so linear fractional optimization
this is you know this is taking a step
from linear optimization the main thing
is that you have this denominator
sitting here so the syntax is identical
in all of these functions which I have
labeled out here now the if you want to
give it in the matrix vector form then
you give it you know you give this Alpha
Beta Gamma Delta
which has these vectors and scalars and
and it will it it goes there and
solstice
now this linear fractional problem
actually can be transformed into a
linear optimization problem so we can
use the exact same solvers that that
linear optimization uses to solve linear
fractional problems and the way you do
that is using this transformation called
chance Cooper transformation which is
this transformations right here and when
you apply this transformation you get
this equivalent optimization problem so
the interesting thing about linear
fractional optimization is where it's
essentially used it's you typically
encounter optimization problems wherein
you want to minimize and maximize
multiple objective functions you want to
minimize cost maximize profit and you
want to do that simultaneously a linear
fractional optimization allows you to do
that so that's one way to do it there
are other ways to do it but linear a
fractional optimization would be one
approach that you could use to solve
these kind of multi objective problems
one thing I do want to point out if for
those who start using this is that you
know because there is a denominator
there's a very good chance that this
denominator could go to 0 which means
that inside the inside this conic the
the region you you could end up getting
singular results but that's the
objective function goes to negative
infinity but you'll still get the value
of X and Z will still be something
finite so that's something to keep in
mind ok so best way to talk about linear
fractional optimization is through an
application problem ok so I'm going to
talk about the transportation problem
it's a it's a toy problem but I'm sure
it will it will convey the underlying
message so what we have is we have v we
have a transportation company
it wants to transport five goods from
point A to point B and there are various
costs associated with it okay so the
cost of transporting these five goods
per unit is 100 across the
but the profit that they make is
different so cost per unit profit for
the unit is given to us okay now
associated with each one of these units
you have a weight right so each each
product pays a certain amount and there
is a maximum number of units that the
that the transportation company can
transport and so that's weight per unit
and max units that it can transport now
the company will have will have some
kind of a minimum operating cost they
own trucks there's fuel cost there's
labor costs something to that effect so
that's like that standard cost is 2,000
in this case and the additional cost
comes with whatever goods that they are
transporting so 2,000 plus cost per unit
dot X and this is where we introduce our
first variable X so X becomes the number
is a vector of five that which basically
represents the number of units you're
going to use which are going to
transport so that's your cost and the
truck makes a profit a minimum profit if
you use the truck company you need to
pay a thousand dollars up front so even
if it rides empty you're gonna it's
going to make a profit of thousand but
then additional profit is made by
basically how much profit by
transporting the goods the truck
obviously has carrying capacity of 8,000
pounds so you can't go above that and it
can't it can't go negative in terms of
carrying the goods so there these are
obvious or rather in the literature they
would be called natural constraints
right so weight constraint and goods
constraint and now that you have set up
the problem the the problem that you're
trying to solve this you want to
minimize the cost maximize the profit
okay that's also called efficiency in in
some jargon so us divided by profit is
what you're trying to minimize you have
weight constraint you have Goods
constraint and you have a vector you
solve the problem and there you have it
and it says that the truck will make its
most profit by just transporting the
first third and the fourth product with
that number
so that's that's this this should give
you an idea and look at the
documentation of this you you'll notice
that this is how we set up the problem
so that's it's quite easy to follow
through okay quadratic optimization
again just for you know the objective
function is going to be quadratic with
linear equality constraints we also
allow for the quadratic optimization
case we also allow you to give what are
called as factored forms and factored
forms turned out to be really important
or really useful rather in data fitting
kinds of problems okay
I'll skip directly to the examples so
that you can see what we're talking
about again I'm going to talk about the
data fitting problem but now it's just a
basic norm fitting right this is the
again exactly the same example I'm going
to use the same basis and do the
interpolation but now notice that
instead of giving the result or rather
the input in the in in the symbolic form
I'm giving it in a matrix vector form
because it just so it it's just obvious
to give it in this form you know you
give the a and B are just directly known
to us this a and B is directly known to
us so rather than introducing new
symbolic variables which make no sense
let's just directly give those things
give those inputs matrix vector inputs
and that's your result and that's your
fit okay so again it just it just works
seamlessly internally it's using there
are there are multiple solvers that you
can invoke there is the coin library
that you can use or you can convert this
problem into a conic optimization
problem and you can use the conic
solvers the dedicated conic solvers to
solve that okay all right a second
example is geometry you know when you're
talking about quadratic problems and
norms you know this idea of distance and
it becomes almost
naturally in these kind of formulations
so in this example I have two regions to
polyhedrus and I want to find the
minimum distance between those two
polyhedrus and so x1 is a point that
that is on region 1 X 2 is a point that
belongs to region 2 I want to find the
minimum distance between those two and
you know that's it's a that's that
that's the formulation so you can find
the minimum value and primal minimizer
rule basically gives you the x1 and x2
so that's the first point that's the
second point ok and this is the minimum
distance between the two and there you
have it okay alright so now the thing
that is often overlooked is the dual
dual is a very very powerful thing if it
takes a little while it takes a little
bit of trying to getting used to
dual concepts but once you do you
realize that it's really it's really
powerful and I want to explain the idea
of dual using the specific example you
know yeah we have this region and we
want to fit we want to find the smallest
ball that encloses this region and it
you can't see so that's the objective
that's the optimization problem you want
to solve minimize are subject to a
number of points that are less than or
equal to R and you want to find this R
and C not the center of the circle of
the of the ball but this is not an optic
or attic optimization problem this
actually is a second-order cone problem
but as it turns out that this problems
duel is actually a quadratic
optimization problem so that's that this
is the dual of this dual formulation
allows you to solve this problem as a
quadratic optimization problem so the W
now turn out to be weights so the center
becomes the weighted sum of all the
points that you have right so that's the
objective you go ahead and get the
weights that's your Center which is
weight and the radius becomes the square
root of the negative of the minimum
value and the negative is because dual
is
with maximizing and objective if your
primal is minimizing then your dual is
maximizing okay and so that's your
radius and then you can visualize this
and there you have it
now I do want to point out that just
because the dual is available and you
can do it it's not always a good idea
for what I'm trying to say is this is
not the most efficient way to solve this
particular problem because this scales
linearly with the number of points and
it's just not as efficient you'd you'd
get a much faster and more accurate
result using second-order cone
optimization but you should you should
know that the dual has is does have a
lot of good properties that you can use
to your benefit okay I'm running a
little short so I'm going to jump to the
second-order cone optimization which is
basically minimize its objective
function is linear but its constraints
have this norm in it okay jump to an
example this is basically you're trying
to find it this the distance between two
discs that are separated and so you know
you have two discs and you want to find
two points one on each disk and you want
to find the minimum distance between
those and those are the two discs and
those are the two points the graphics
makes it much easier to to tell the
story and and you can find the distance
between those two directly from from the
from the result or you can compute it
yourself they're going to be the same
okay
I'm gonna skip this example because I
really want to talk about sensitivity
analysis well I have so here's and I
want to talk about it in terms of an
example let's say that you have you know
a company that's that's manufacturing
three products but it uses four machines
to do that and you know that's the
distribution and it has a number of
constraints that you can't run the
machine for a certain number of times
you have a maximum capacity on the
products and what-have-you so you set up
the constraints and then you solve the
problem and then you say that okay
the the profit that I get for for this
problem of of manufacturing these three
products is seven thousand six hundred
whatever but the real question and the
power of sensitivity analysis comes in
is what can I do how can I analyze this
problem so I can increase my profit okay
what can I do there and that's where
sensitivity analysis comes on its own
you can you can extract the constraint
sensitivity which is just a vector of
numbers and you'll notice that some of
these sensitivities have zero what that
zero means is that these the constraints
that belong to this zero vector the zero
elements don't have any effect on your
bottom line on your profit so you can
you can you can change them in whatever
you where you want but your profits are
not going to change on the other hand
you have three constraints that if you
do make any changes to them you should
see an increase or decrease in profit so
that tells you that
so that's your analysis tool right there
so let's extract the ones that that give
you a direct effect on the profit and
you'll see that the first one it says
that you know if your increase X 3
should be greater than or equal to 60
means that you know that the third
product the maximum I can produce a 60
if I increase that second product 2 in
to producing 70 I should see a increase
in profit so max 1 I get and max 0 was
this so I do get a increase in profit if
I don't change that if I increase 1 or 2
right I see no change in profit so
rather than running these examples over
and over again you can use sensitivity
analysis to your advantage to do really
useful analysis ok I'm way over time so
I'm gonna I'm going to stop now and I'm
going to take any questions
and enjoy this plot questions
you
[Applause]